oh
la direction des musées de france m'a
offert l'occasion unique de composer une
exposition à partir des collections du
louvre le choix que j'ai fait de l'art
maniériste m'a permis d'illustrer deux
idées qui me sont chers d'une part
réaliser une exposition de type
pluridisciplinaire c'est-à-dire qu'ils
associent différentes techniques la
peinture la gravure le dessin la
sculpture à tapissier objets d'art et
d'autre part fait rentrer dans une la
proportion les collections propre du
musée des beaux-arts de rennes la
composition de cette exposition est donc
le résultat d'un grand mariage
une autre raison était de présenter une
des plus récentes conquêtes de
l'histoire de l'art encore mal connue du
grand public
un style enfin étudié pour lui même et
qui est peut-être le plus inventif
le plus étonnant de tous parfaitement
situé dans l'espace et le temps
l' empire maniériste est vaste il
dépasse les frontières nationales
c'est toute l'europe occidentale et sa
durée elle s'étend sur un siècle entier
15 120 à 1620 environ
n
moment
le maniérisme est un art qui refuse
toutes les tentations toutes les
séductions du réalisme il utilise bien
sûr des formes qui sont prises dans la
nature mais il ne les considère pas
comme la fin de la création elles sont
simplement un langage un des motifs qui
ont le plus séduit les artistes
maniériste est celui du grotesque cette
mode ce motif a traversé tout le siècle
peut-on dire et par le canal de l'est
stampe il a été largement diffusée on le
retrouve dans l'art de la tapisserie
dans celui de la céramique
ce tableau de jules romains qui a pour
sujet la circoncision offre plusieurs
caractères qui peuvent servir à définir
le maniérisme la même intensité est
importé à tous les détails à tous les
personnages qui remplissent complètement
l'espace également ce qu'il faut noter
c'est l'apparenté indifférence des
personnages à la scène représenter les
personnages sont traitées pour eux mêmes
comme des motifs décoratifs et il y a
une impression qui s'impose à la
première vision c'est celle qui relie
entre eux les deux motifs de ce tableau
les personnages d'une part et de l'autre
les immenses colonnes torses qui
soutiennent ce temple de sorte que tout
l'ensemble du tableau semble agité par
une salutation qui en fait le ballet du
maniérisme
dans le monde fantastique du maniérisme
il existe une définition
particulièrement typique de l'espace
elle n'est de l'imagination
rien n'illustre mieux que le célèbre
tableau dont antoine caron la sibylle de
timur nous sommes là dans une scène de
théâtre au sens tact divers et qui tous
sont traités avec le même souci du
détail le tournoi au fond la prédiction
de la sibylle au premier plan autant de
motifs étrange inattendue d'une gratuité
totale et dany réalisme charmant les
personnages ont des attitudes de
danseurs et ils sont peints dans des
couleurs introuvable
la célébration du héros prend ses
modèles dans l'histoire ancienne avec
scipion dont la grandeur d'âme est
montrée en exemple dans le monde
poétique avec les héros romanesque
tancrède et clorinde de la jérusalem
délivrée dans l'histoire sainte avec
judith toutes parts et de la puissance
séductrice et qui s'attache à la
faiblesse triomphant de la brutalité
mais ce peut être aussi un prince du 16e
siècle henry 2 qui accède au monde des
héros corps sans vie
mais n'ont pas détruit par la mort dans
ce mémorial exceptionnel commandé par
catherine de médicis à germain pilon les
dieux chez les hommes pourquoi ce titre
parce que jamais comme au 16e siècle
la présence de la mythologie n'a été
aussi vivante dans le décor des palais 7
ces visites divine privilégie deux
aspects celui de la métamorphose qui en
général
puni les humains qui veulent rivaliser
avec les dieux et celui du
travestissement dans lequel jupiter est
passé le roi
cette tapisserie comme son pendant ont
une origine royal il s'agit de commande
faite aux ateliers de fontainebleau par
le roi henry 2 pour le château de diane
de poitiers annette ceci est prouvé par
l'existence sur cette api three des
initiales h&b henry diane et d'une façon
plus poétique par l'alternance des
fleurs de lys et du croissant de diane
cette tapisserie illustre bien un des
caractères du maniérisme qui est
l'illusion
en effet de part et d'autre d'un motif
central
on a une répartition globale de masse
similaire mais qui diffère jusque dans
le moindre détail
et d'autre part il illustre belle
illustre bien également un autre aspect
de cet art qui est celui d'une invention
nouvelles de l'espace puisque dans ce
monde du suspendu tout devient habitable
le décor cesse d'être une catégorie à
part et tout art devient ardu décor
comme en témoigne cet exceptionnel étude
de casque qui dans sa totalité est conçu
comme une inquiétante tête d'oiseau et
qui dans ses détails fait apparaître une
succession d'éléments empruntés aux
trois règnes de la nature végétal animal
et humain comme sur sept est guère
italienne le bec est formé d'un dauphin
d'autres plats italiens présentent le
décor de grotesque que nous avons déjà
observé en france
la principale originalité avec bernard
palissy réside dans les céramiques à
relief ultime témoignage de luxe cette
peinture sur un sujet en lui-même
précieux la pêche des perles est exécuté
sur des plaques de lapis lazuli l'europe
du 16e siècle reste chrétienne même si
la tunique du christ désormais n'est
plus aux coutures dans ce contexte
l'imagerie chrétienne ne cesse pas
d'intéresser mais les artistes
maniériste n'oppose pas ses exigences à
celle du paganisme les deux registres
simultanément s'offrent aux artistes
pour traduire l'expérience humaine
avec l'église de la contre-réforme le
conflit viendra non pas tant d audace
des libertés de l'art maniériste que
d'une conception purement esthétique de
l'art le moins engagé qui fut jamais au
début du xviie siècle
la courbe est désormais complète les
outrances les excès de l'hyper
maniérisme confirment la continuité de
la vie des formes de ce style
plus que jamais le mouvement reste un
mouvement international français avec un
artiste comme vignon qui dans ce tableau
de la mort de saint termites montre tout
ça son audace composition très dense
extraordinaire succession de visages qui
sont comme les différents âges de la vie
ou bien allemand avec cette vanité cette
allégorie de la vanité représente très
sous les traits de la comédie ou encore
prague oit dans ce chef-d'oeuvre de
sprunger
c'est inoubliable allégorie de la
justice qui déploie une grande forme
serpentine comme cent ans plus tôt la
première vague du maniérisme on avait
trouvé mais ici avec cet éclair de
bronze qui déchire la nuit on atteint
l'un des sommets de l'art maniériste un
art meurt de ses outrances
mais il lui arrive quelquefois de mourir
sur ses champs les plus beaux les plus
graves ceux qui nous atteignent nous
moderne de plus près
on
e